un crimen de guerra hacían calificado
las autoridades palestinas a una de las
mayores operaciones del ejército Israel
en 20 años en las discordania ocupada
hace un llamado a la comunidad
internacional y anuncia la ruptura de
cooperación en materia de seguridad con
Israel con la finalización de los
acuerdos
hacemos de nuevo un llamado a la
comunidad internacional para que brinde
protección urgente a nuestro pueblo e
imponga sanciones contra el régimen de
ocupación
pero su contraparte el Primer Ministro
israelí justifica la operación Y promete
continuar con ella
en los últimos meses se ha convertido en
un paraíso para el terrorismo estamos
poniendo fin a eso continuaremos con esa
operación todo el tiempo que sea
necesario para devolver la calma y la
seguridad al pueblo de Israel
los ataques han afectado a civiles este
campamento de refugiados en la ciudad de
yening fue blanco de los aviones no
tripulados
Hoy es un día oscuro
en el campamento como ya lo hicieron en
según la media luna roja Palestina
alrededor de 500 familias tuvieron que
huir ya Hay muertos y los heridos que
son trasladados a hospitales cercanos
son hostigados por las fuerzas de
defensa de Israel que se enfrentan a
tiros en las calles contra militantes
palestinos
la ONU y algunos países aliados
históricos de Israel como Reino Unido
han condenado la violencia el ejército
Israel y en yin a nivel regional Irán
enemigo Israel se pronunció
los ataques en curso contra la ciudad
indefensa de jenín demuestran una vez
más que la paz el compromiso y la
normalización de los lazos no son
efectivos en absoluto para detener la
maquinaria de guerra del régimen
sionista
cisjordania vive su mayor pico de
violencia desde la segunda intifada solo
en 2023 cerca de 200 palestinos han
muerto por enfrentamientos con Israel
las milicias palestinas entre ellas
jamás y la yihad islámica advirtieron de
que la continuación de la operación
militar en yin conducirá una amplia
escalada y prometieron responder a la
agresión israelí